days of heavy rain have caused havoc in
the city of durban
one of africa's largest ports
shipping containers have been carried
away or strewn across submerged
motorways into splits commuters forced
to abandon their vehicles and walk
train services across quasi-natal
province have been suspended to clear
the rails after land and mudslides
thousands of houses and informal homes
have been damaged and families displaced
jumba pulled his youngest child from the
soil pouring onto his home
i got no way to go now
i got no house i got no nothing yes my
family is there by my neighbors
we tried to give you the place to
sleep last night
we never
we never sleep last night
the things very situation is very very
bad
mathunzie was asleep in his truck and
says he made a narrow escape
excellent
at 3am i felt the truck shaking and i
thought maybe someone bumped it and when
i opened the curtain i saw the water
level was very high
with the motorways linking the port to
the commercial capital johannesburg
submerged underwater global shipping
firm maersk has suspended its operations
the flooding has also damaged parts of
the city that had just rebuilt from
riots last july
cleaning up the road after the severe
rain from last night washing down the
bud in the banks of people's houses and
since we've been trying to get people to
come and sort it out no one's come so
the residents are not taking charge
the south african weather service won't
attribute the storms to climate change
but says this kind of rain may become
the new normal in the years ahead
andrew chappelle al jazeera